Speaker 1: All right. It is mailbag time well into
the depths of the mailbag, as you can imagine.
Now, towards the end of January. You can email
info at David Pakman dot com if you would like.
You can also sometimes be featured in the mailbag
based on YouTube comments, Facebook messages,
tweets not typically Tik Tok posts or responses,
but maybe someday. In any case, let's just jump
right in because there is so much meaty substance.
This week, Jeremy wrote in to me about critical
race theory. And Jeremy says, David, I've been
listening to your show for a while now, and you
are so triggered about critical race theory. You
were in a meltdown talking about Arkansas banning
CRT in their schools. Honestly, why are you so
upset about this if they supposedly don't teach it
in the first place? It seems like you support CRT
in schools. I seriously want to know if you do.
Listen, I am not melting down about what's
happening in Arkansas. I'm worried that a
disastrous state is just wasting money, time and
resources on things that won't help them improve
education. Arkansas is a disaster on education.
I gave you all of the statistics in my segment
last week about Sarah Huckabee Sanders banning
critical race theory. What upsets me about it
is that the people of Arkansas voted for someone
who was clearly being selected to do this type of
nonsense virtue signaling rather than fixing the
economy or getting jobs there or dealing with the
horrible educational numbers or any of it. She
bans something that just isn't happening, and
she claims to be a small government conservative.
So I have no plans to live in Arkansas. I feel
bad for the people that that do in the sense that
it's not even just that culturally I couldn't take
it. They have had a string of leaders that just
waste their taxpayer money, of which they don't
really have that much. Quite frankly, Arkansas
very much depending on the federal dole and do
things that are just a waste of time and money.
So it's not that I'm melting down. It's that it's
a terrible thing for the people of Arkansas. And I
feel bad for them. I feel very, very bad for them.
Trump, D.L. wrote in about Trump and says, Why
are you so obsessed with Trump? Get over it.
You never talk about the Biden crime family. They
have been corrupt for over 40 years. Maybe because
of your age you didn't know this, but you could
educate yourself now. Looks like the Dems want
him out. He's a fool. Even Obama mentioned
it on tape. Obama Now, I don't know what
D.L. is talking about. I have no idea what he's
talking about. And remember Biden crime, family
investigate Biden for the classified documents
stuff. If there was wrongdoing, do whatever you
need to do, but keep investigating Trump as well,
because the situations are very different. Hunter
Biden. If Hunter Biden did something criminal
or potentially criminal law enforcement and the
Justice Department should investigate. Charge
the guy. If he's guilty, throw him in jail.
I don't care. But for Republicans to make Hunter
Biden the foremost political issue is disgusting.
Hunter Biden has nothing to do with the Biden
administration, unlike Ivanka and Jared and so on.
And to take up congressional time as they plan
to do investigating Hunter. Give me a break. It's
pathetic. So I don't know what the hell is talking
about. But Dlss seems very, very triggered.
Justin wrote in. Justin says, I treat your show
like the news because I'm not particularly fond of
TV news. Though I do watch other TV commentary
like Chris Hayes, that Lawrence guy, Ari and
others from MSNBC. I actually listen to all of
them through clips on YouTube. You should have
a segment on your show where you cover multiple
recent headlining national and international
stories. 5 to 7 offer a quick commentary and move
on to the next thing. You'd pick up people looking
for quick news. You know, we tried this and nobody
watched it. There's this interesting thing that
happens, and I don't know if it's a blessing or a
curse. I really don't, Justin But sometimes when
you do your show a certain way for a while and
you build an audience based on that, it's easy
to think, Hey, you know, if I did this other thing
that other people have success with, I would just
double my success. I would do so, so, so well. But
oftentimes when you test those things, it doesn't
happen. And I don't know the reason why. Maybe
it's because I've been pigeonholed into doing the
type of show I do. Maybe it's because I wouldn't
be good at doing a 5 to 7 story news segment,
but for whatever reason, when we tried it. Nobody
watched it. I am always interested in trying new
formats and ideas, but that particular one didn't
work when we tried it in the past. Dave wrote in
and says, I enjoy watching your YouTube posts.
That said, it is quite distracting when you're
playing back things and pause to make comments.
I'd rather hear more of the video and then hear
your take on it. So listen, this has been a
disagreement among some of my audience for a long
time. I have taken the position based on what I do
and the emails that I've received that most people
are watching this, listening to this to hear
my commentary. Now, you could say, well, fine,
but keep your commentary for after the clip. When
I did that, we tested doing that. I got a ton of
emails from people saying, David, you know, I get
that news stations will often just play a clip in
its entirety and then like, say something later.
But the reason I'm watching you is actually for
you to pause and break down. Break it down piece
by piece. So, David, this is just a preference.
And with peace and love. I appreciate that you
don't like it. Every time we've adjudicated this,
every time we've investigated this, the the
consensus is the majority. Not everybody, but the
majority is. David, keep doing it the way you do
it. When you want to pause and tell us something
about the clip. Let us know. Wrote in. Now, this
one, this is tongue in cheek. Okay? Zachary says.
David, I've been listening to your show for years,
and the last few weeks you've been talking about
George Santos and his supposed lies. To think
somebody would spread such horrible claims about
the first man on the moon is sickening. Not only
that, he is the president of the United States,
the king of England, and the world's tallest man.
So have some respect. You should be ashamed of
yourself, David. Do better. The King of England
thing is funny. I once interviewed a guy named
David Wynn Miller, who's since passed away. May
he rest in peace. And he David Wynn Miller was
known for. I believe he did. Anyway, if he's still
alive, then I apologize. David, when Miller was
known for, quote, teaching people to stuff their
names full of punctuation marks like semicolons
and dashes and stuff, which he said would make
you nontaxable. It didn't work. People would get
thrown in jail for contempt when they tried it.
But he claimed that he was the king of Hawaii.
It was it was quite a ride, I have to tell you.
But in any case, George Santos. Yes, a very,
very honest man. Jeff wrote in and says, good
morning. I find it hypocritical that the people
questioning vaccines due to some athletes having
health issues are so fast to dismiss why we are
seeing once in a generation weather events that
seem to be occurring monthly. I'd like to hear
your thoughts. Thanks for the great content. So,
Liz, here's the deal. This is a very common thing
in politics. Left and right, do it. But right
now it's being weaponized much more by the right.
If you find an anomaly and you want to
use it to claim that it is the status quo,
you do it. And if you find an anomaly and
it is useful for it to be merely an anomaly,
then you say it's just an anecdote, it's just
an anomaly. And so although climate science
tells us that we should expect exactly what
we've been seeing, extreme high temperatures,
extreme low temperatures, weather events
being more serious, more frequent hurricanes,
all these different things. That's not the story
that works. So they say this is just weather. It's
not climate. Forget about it, whatever. On the
other hand, when it comes to an expected number of
young people dying. Remember, we went through the
numbers. There has not actually been an increase.
They want to tell the story that it's an
epidemic because of the vaccine. They just do it.
The facts in the science simply do not matter.
Andrew Rhoden And says Marjorie Taylor GREENE on
the Homeland Security Committee with Marjorie
Taylor GREENE on this committee, asks Andrew,
Should I, as a Jew, be concerned about the
investigation of our space lasers? Listen, Andrew.
If they want to come and take the
space lasers, that's one thing.
But if Marjorie Taylor GREENE comes from a
chocolate babka, she will take it from my cold,
dead hands. That I guarantee you, sir. Michelle
wrote in about trolls. Speaking of which,
more comments tonight from listeners who scorn
you, David. I find it astounding and sad that
there are so many people who have nothing better
to do than listen to podcasters they dislike.
Personally, I struggle to find time to keep up
with the podcasters and news sources that I like.
I can't imagine wasting time following anyone
I disliked. I guess some people just aren't
happy unless they're hating someone, hating on
someone so sad. Yet this is a really good point.
I don't have the time to watch the shows. I want
to watch to keep up with the podcasts I like. I
don't have time for it to read the books I want
to read. The idea that I would waste any time with
the stuff I don't like is is laughable. But again,
these people have no lives. Michelle. That's what
you have to remember. Info at David Pakman
dot com. If you have something to say to me.
Say it to my face and I mean that by email.
Info at David Pakman dot com. We have such
a great week of programs coming up for you
next week. But we have the bonus show first.
Speaker 2: A bonus show where you get to
make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad. Thank you. Your
lucky stars every day. You're not David.
Speaker 1: Pakman. Well, many in our audience
do. Alex you can sign up at join Pacman dot
com. Let's make it a thing. We'll see you then.